we start this NewsHour in China where
the leader credited with steering the
country to Global power has died former
president James was 96. he came to
office just after the 1989 Tiananmen
Square protests and Crackdown he's seen
as one of the architects of China's
transformation into a market economy
Katrina you looks back on his life
rare among Chinese leaders younger men
seemed to enjoy the spotlight he stepped
into the top job during a turbulent
period he was appointed Communist Party
general secretary in June 1989 following
the military Crackdown on student-led
protests in Tiananmen Square his
predecessor Charles young had been
removed from power for openly
sympathizing with the demonstrators
Zhang was the former mayor of Shanghai a
city then at the Forefront of ambitious
economic reforms slowly spreading across
the country those reforms would
eventually allow China to grow into the
world's second largest economy in
Shanghai into a Global Financial hub
although China presents itself as a
communist country an increasing number
of party members are becoming
Millionaires and some billionaires
as economic growth surged under junk
foreign investment poured in
1997 patriotic Pride sought when Britain
returned Hong Kong in 1999 Jung
initiated a ruthless campaign against
the spiritual practice of falun gong
Human Rights group said hundreds of
thousands of people were imprisoned or
sent to labor camps under his rule China
became a member of the World Trade
Organization
and was also awarded the 2008 Olympics
but some things remained unchanged the
leadership continued to crack down on
descent
China's marketization of its centrally
planned economy brought dangers the gap
between rich and poor widened and
Corruption worsened a legacy junk
successor hujin Tao inherited in 2002.
in Chinese history only Mao Zedong dong
Xiaoping and the current president Xi
Jinping larger than Zhang it remains to
be seen whether he will receive the same
reverence as China builds its position
on the global stage
well Katrina you joins us live from
Beijing now and Katrina can you tell us
more about his legacy and what the
reaction has been so far there
well State media just informed the
public of his passing this afternoon
Wednesday afternoon expressing profound
grief over his death saying that he was
a great revolutionary and a long-tested
communist fighter so they're really
upping his Communist Party credentials
when they talk about him but
that he's remembered among the people as
so much more he couldn't have been any
more different to the rather
straight-faced or serious officials that
we often see in China today it's
certainly very very different to China's
current leadership Xi Jinping who's sort
of portrayed as an emperor uh Min by
contrast was seen as more of an every
man he had his characteristic thick
heavy set black glasses and he often
spoke quite candidly and quite
frequently to the Press he used English
quite often he even gave entire speeches
in English he was fond of for example
singing Italian songs in front of
foreign dignitaries and it was well
known that he played the piano and would
often make jokes uh when speaking
publicly that's not to say he was not a
serious leader though during his 13
years of ruling China China essentially
transformed into somewhat of a pariah
state after the 1989 [ __ ] Square
Crackdown into a Global superpower he
implemented many economic reforms that
had been instigated by his predecessor
Deng Xiaoping and in which saw China
opened up more uh became more of a
globalized country than it had ever been
before he also oversaw China's rejoin uh
joining of the World Trade Organization
in 2001 and of course also the Handover
of Hong Kong back to Mainland China in
1997. now all of that is not to say that
he wasn't a tough or by any means a
progressive leader he also oversaw a
Crackdown as we just heard over the
spiritual movement falun gong and also
repressed many uh protests in the
Countryside by Farmers because of some
of his reforms and at the same time he
carried out a very coercive sort of
approach towards Taiwan and while he was
in power China also saw a lot of
corruption uh flourished throughout many
of its officials okay Katrina you thank
you very much for that
well Victor gals the vice president of
the center for China and globalization
he is also in Beijing and joins us now
live thank you very much for being on Al
Jazeera now I understand you knew him
personally we heard from Katrina there
that he was incredibly charismatic what
were some of uh the other attributes
that made him a great leader
we're all very sorry for the loss of uh
former party Secretary General mean
today I knew him personally in the 1980s
I even traveled on the same special
playing seated next to him for a travel
of more than two hours so I know him
personally and I think his legacy is a
very great legacy because he was the top
leader of China for about 13 years and
then his influence actually reached into
the fourth generation and until very
recently is very much revered and
respected in China and his leadership of
China really oversaw China overcoming
the uh very difficult challenge in times
in the early 1990s I'm normalizing the
relations with the United States and the
West at large and also joining WTO for
example which paved the way for the
subsequent rapid economic transformation
of China and uh Mr a gentleman was also
a very Humane figure he knows many
languages foreign languages as well as
domestic Chinese dialects for example is
very sophisticated and very Cosmopolitan
and he knows where he wants to lead
China and he has left a very deep
fingerprint on the political system in
China on the Chinese military as well as
of how China need to open up and
continue economic and political reforms
it's a great loss to the Chinese nation
and I think his morning the morning for
his passing away and his legacy will be
really very much memorialized in the
coming few days okay he came to power
after the Tiananmen Square protest can
you explain what the country was like
then and the hurdles that he had to
overcome at that time
I would say Mr Johnson mean became the
party Secretary General the president of
the People's Republic of China and
eventually the chairman of the central
military uh commission more or less by
accident in 1989 was about to retire and
he was of course a member of the
political standing political standing
committee of course however I think what
happened in 1989 really brought the
positions and opportunities to him
because he was really very well
qualified at that critical moment and
the subsequent years of his leadership
also proved that his his decision was a
correct decision for the Chinese
Communist party for the military and for
the whole nation as a whole and I would
say his sophistication his knowledge
space his knowledge about China versus
the rest of the world and the fact that
he was actually based in the former
Soviet Union in the
1950s and also worked for a while in
Rome Mania for example also broadened
his view about the outside of the uh
China and eventually the fact that he
was very much involved in the leadership
of China's opening up to the outside
world foreign trade Machinery building
for example and also leading the great
city of Shanghai paved the way and
created all the credentials for him to
eventually be promoted to the top
position in China and I think the human
side is also very important for his
leadership and during his leadership
China was really a very happy period of
time everyone was improving their living
standards and China's relations with the
rest of the world especially with the
Western countries will improved
significantly just on that you you
describe him as a very significant man
but his government also Stamped Out to
send jailed human rights and
pro-democracy activists that is also
part of his Legacy isn't it
thank you
well I would say either in the 1990s or
in the 21st century or even now
maintaining stability in China has
always been the most important
overriding task without stability we
cannot afford to really significantly
improve our economic uh situation and
thus improving the living standards of
the people therefore maintaining
stability and fighting against any
reason or any forces which would deprive
China of stability has been a constant
challenge for China and I think the
former leader Johnson May did a good job
in maintaining stability Paving the way
for China's reconnection with the rest
of the world and eventually the whole
Chinese people really benefited Christ's
wisdom his dedication his sophistication
his cosmopolitanism for example and his
eagerness to push for greater opening of
not to the rest of the world okay thank
you so much for joining us on Al Jazeera
that is Victor gar the vice president of
the center for China and globalization
thank you